but the one thing you they do not  eat compromise on is when a fighter  misses weight it's the one thing man  it's the one thing the uc has zero  tolerance for that's the only time where  i've skeptical hip hip boys  something's going on there where  it was  agreed to way before that he was going  to come in 180 pounds i think  i think that fans were turned off by ufc  and especially dana white in particular  his treatment of nate diaz they just  don't give him a fight they give him the  worst matchup possible  and i think fans and i said this on find  the kid a clip that went pretty viral  for me  you know if you're a nate diaz fan the  way you  show the ufc that this isn't right and  we don't agree with this and listen i  love nate d as much as you guys do but  the way that you would the only way you  can affect the ufc's bottom line but  then you have to affect the nate diaz  bottom line so it's tricky but the only  way to fight back kids is don't buy the  paper